ist dann finger alter ich da ganz ihre
finger lage drin aber das wäre hart was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ja weil ich hoffe natürlich
euch jetzt gut ich bin na ja wie soll
ich sagen ich bin heute ein bisschen
vorsichtig mit dem was ich sage weil so
videos in denen man irgendwas kaputt
macht fahr' ich eigentlich auch nicht
ich meine warum sollte man sachen kaputt
machen ich würde ich aber mal eben die
vorgeschichte erzählen und zwar wurden
wir vor drei vier wochen also und video
angezeigt da hat jemand airports
aufgemacht und auch das airport case ich
habe nochmal ein bisschen google oder im
internet gibt sehr viele fotos für leute
halt warum auch immer
original airports oder auch airports
frau auseinander genommen haben um zu
zeigen was da drin ist ist ja auch an
sich relativ interessant ich höre jetzt
niemals auf die idee kam eine originalen
airports auf zu machen weil ich sind ja
danach höchstwahrscheinlich kaputt das
sei denn man macht halt wirklich sehr
sehr vorsichtig und trotzdem habe ich
mir gedacht bestellt sie jedoch mal eben
wieder neue fag airports halt wirklich
das billigste vom billigsten und diese
hier sind geworden
[Applaus]
die bombe war stehengeblieben auf jeden
fall habe ich erfurt fix bestellt für
keine ahnung sechs euro also das video
ist schon ein bisschen länger geplant
ich habe hier auch noch welche liegen so
ähnliche dass wir müssen die i7 tws sein
habe ich ja auch bestimmt irgendwann
schon mal ausgepackt und ich habe mir
gedacht wir machen die heute mal auf
eine möglichkeit auf und schauen wir mal
rein weil ich habe mich jetzt so oft mit
etwas auseinander gesetzt und ich finde
wenn das mal einer machen darf wenn ich
ich bin absolut kein technik experte
aber dann können wir das natürlich mal
so ein bisschen vergleichen mit den
originalen airport weil die hier kostet
januar 41 vom original
und ja es wird eigentlich ansteht aus ne
bevor irgendein video das zeige hier
vielleicht mal ein foto
so sieht er trotz der ersten generation
von innen aus ich habe mal gesehen jetzt
hier die airports brocken da ist wer
also das sieht schon krass aus
hier kann man auch sehen wie man die
öffnen kann ok ich weiß jetzt nicht ob
das hier ausgeht und schneide ich dir
halt einfach auf habe man muss ja schon
sagen da ist ziemlich viel drin in
diesem kleinen dinge und wir schauen mal
was sich hier in versteckt ob man da
irgendwas interessantes finden kann
vielleicht ist auch total langweilig ich
weiß es nicht aber ich habe mir einfach
diesen gedanken im kopf gesetzt dass nur
zu machen und deswegen 9 jedes mal auf
ich weiß auch dass so ein kanal gibt in
amerika what's inside heißt ja die
schneiden einfach immer so sachen auf
ich finde es wirklich interessant ich
weiß nicht ob wir dafür offen sein für
sowas sachen halt mal kurz kaputt zu
machen und wie gesagt die waren nicht
teuer deswegen ich hoffe da kann man
drüberstehen so entschuldigung ich hoffe
das stellt das jetzt scharf wenn ihr
euch jetzt mal hier den kopfhörer
anschaut
ich finde da sieht eigentlich ganz gut
verarbeitet sogar auch und ich müssten
eigentlich ziemlich easy auf bekommt bei
dem case vermutlich ein bisschen
schwieriger bin gleich wieder da das
messer ach wat für messer hammer das
ging richtig sie jetzt habe ich dann
einfach hier
schon aufgekommen ich kann das sogar
wieder zu machen und dann funktioniert
er sich weil ich wieder hier guckt
wieder heile perfekt machen
juli ist gerade auf dabei komme also wir
haben jetzt auf gekriegt hatte ich wohl
das hier war alles raus jetzt ist auch
egal
also ich bin euch jetzt durchgehend das
foto einen von den originalen airports
das ist natürlich hier schon was anderes
nicht
hast du eine ahnung was das sein kann
wahrscheinlich die batterien aus china
er war kurz ich muss mal ganz kurz in
wasser der migros die ganz jungen alter
dass wir unten muss bitte schalten recht
werden
wer so lustig
[Musik]
was machst du musst du musst ja auch
echt werbung schalten das werde erst
habe ich jetzt habe ich sie mit hier
rucksack okay das war's auch schon mal
wenn ich das jetzt also zumal hier drauf
das ist alles was in den sieben tws
drittes mehr nicht und wenn man das
jetzt mit den originalen vergleich ist
schon leichter unterschied aber wir
haben jetzt nichts merkwürdiges gebunden
weil das hat ja auch sein können aber es
kommt noch dass kate das will ich auch
auf jeden fall noch kurz öffnen also an
die techniker unter euch wenn euch
irgendwas auf welt schreibt es mir sehr
sehr gerne in die kommentare
da muss ich leider passen ich habe von
so was nicht planung obwohl ich im
informatik leistungs muss man ja hast du
jahre haben es da programmiert und leser
haben 16 programmpunkte damit gemacht
fußball spiel programmiert für diese
informatik und das ist nie fertig
geworden ist weil irgendwo niemand hat
es geht um so allemann was cooles noch
ein werden wir noch mal auf facebook
erzählt mal daumen hoch wenn ihr in der
schule im informatik uns nur sitzen
still nach jetzt fällt mir auch ich muss
ganz kurz auch noch das airport case
einmal zeigen ja also leute hier sind
vielleicht ein paar fotos und so sehen
originale airports von innen aus weiter
machst du das nicht das normale jo ok
auch ganz interessant
dann bin ich mal gespannt was ich im
vergleich dazu jetzt in den fake teilen
wir verbirgt und es sind halt wirklich
die billigsten jemand überhaupt reden
kann wenn er jetzt sagt macht aber auch
mal welche auf die vielleicht 30 jahre
kosten zu müssen die 1000 ews reißt du
in die kommentare aber ich glaube wenn
ich das jetzt einmal gemacht hat den
billigsten interessanter geht's halt
nicht mehr auch wenn ich noch nicht ganz
weiß ob es noch interessanter wird
also das war es auch schon jetzt kann
ich hier ganz einfach das hier oben raus
ziehen
[Musik]
ja krass ja gut so muss das aussehen
kann man so will es auch
den originalen aussehen ich finde das
eigentlich wirklich immer interessant
weil als kunde
man hat dann im endeffekt dieses fertige
produkt in der hand aber es gibt ja
leute die dieses ganze dinge entwickeln
und die müssen sich natürlich über so
was halt gedanken machen okay dann haben
wir hier wahrscheinlich ich hatte ja
noch nie also natürlich man kennt handy
akkus aber hier ist jetzt der akku
drinnen kann der akku ist sogar
festgeklebt
er muss ja der akku sein
guck mal hier ja alter custom klein
bisschen technik kann den sound erzeugen
und das noch über bluetooth da muss man
sich auch mal also wie weit die technik
ist das echt krass also mich erstaunt 30
das mal kurz ab ich glaube da ist was
kaputt gegangen und hier unten drin
haben wir jetzt halt nur noch so eine
art motherboard wenn ganz mini ich hoffe
ihr könnt das sehen
also wenn ich jetzt auch mal das innere
des cases vergleiche mit zum beispiel
diesem foto hier sieht man ja dass
deutlich mehr drin also deutlich
deutlich mehr haben wir halt nicht nur
den akku das war es ja schon
und hier unten dieses ringen also um das
jetzt mal festzuhalten ich weiß nicht ob
das nur für mich interessant ist oder
für euch auch also dass ein video da
kann ich gar nicht einschätzen ob sich
da irgendwie juckt es dann fingern alter
ich dachte fingernagel drin war das wäre
hart
ich muss das daraus kriegen was ich da
noch sagen heute es ist ja interessant
dass man über verschiedene wege
praktisch so sound erzeugen kann also im
original per post es ja deutlich mehr
verbaut und dadurch dass da mehr
einzelne vermutlich auch bessere technik
produkte eingebaut sind ist der sound
halt deutlich besser als bei diesem hier
mit denen aber auch ein sound erzeugt
werden kann der dann weniger gutes die
frage ist dann was würde passieren wenn
man die sachen aus dem originalen die
hier halt fehlen hier hinzufügt ist der
sound dann besser
es kann gut sein dass leute zu hause
sich jetzt vom kopf schlagen und ich
denke was labert der da aber das sind
halt so meine gedanken gehen
wahrscheinlich geht das auch gar nicht
dass man sachen aus den original hier
rein baut ich habe keine ahnung naja
leute es war trotzdem ein video was ich
mal gemacht haben sollten
und vielleicht fand der eine andere sehr
interessant das reicht mir schon
wir sehen uns dann vermutlich morgen um
19 uhr wieder gibt es ein neues video
abonnieren den kanal auf dem weg zu
einer million und ab dem 16 12 18 uhr
gibt es auf den neuen alex wii shop zum
beispiel hier
dieses urteil könnte ja gern mal
vorbeischauen ist in der bildungsstadt
verlinkt würde ich mich sehr freuen
und ja instagram alexi ii